Since Russia invaded Ukraine, maps of the
conflict are everywhere.
In most cases, shaded areas, like this red
are meant to symbolize territory occupied
by Russian forces
or at least, territory Russia and Ukraine
are fighting over.
In general, this red is referring to
ground troops, like these.
The more the Russian ground troops advance,
the more of the map turns red.
But what maps like these don’t show
is another battle
that’s taking place high above Ukraine.
Where a small Ukrainian air force is fighting
a powerful Russian one
for control of the skies.
What happens here could determine not just
the course of the war
but whether it escalates and spreads
beyond Ukraine.
It’s why Ukraine’s allies are scrambling
to send it weapons.
And some are asking to go a step further:
"No-fly zone."
"A no-fly zone."
[chanting] "No-fly zone!"
"A humanitarian no-fly zone."
"No-fly zone seems to make sense."
"Well, I think you that all know
what I'm going to say."
"We need the no-fly zone over Ukraine."
So, why are the stakes of this air war
so high?
And what would a no-fly zone change?
On February 24, 2022, the Russian invasion
of Ukraine began.
And in terms of military strategy, it followed
a common script.
First, Russian missiles targeted
Ukraine’s radar system.
Then its airfields and some missile launchers.
To military experts, this appeared to be
preparation for a crucial step.
Send a lot of planes to destroy
the Ukrainian air force
and achieve what’s called “Air Superiority."
So when we say a military has air superiority
what we're essentially saying is a military
more or less controls the skies.
With air superiority, Russia could freely
attack Ukrainian ground troops
and protect its own ground troops
who could move faster without fear
of being attacked from the skies.
If Russia were able to establish virtually
unchallenged air superiority
it would be a disaster for Ukraine.
Doesn't mean you're guaranteed a victory
but it makes that victory a heck of a lot more likely.
That's why since World War II
winning air superiority has been
the first step in most invasions.
But in this case, the big attack never came.
And experts don’t really agree on why.
My best informed guess is that
Russians thought that they would be welcome
when they got there.
And so when they saw men, women, and children
blocking their tanks from entering
Ukrainian villages
that surprised them.
When you make war plans, including plans related
to air superiority
if your assumptions are wrong, then your plan
is messed up.
Whatever happened, it means that, more than
two weeks into the invasion
Russia did not have total air superiority.
It allowed the Ukrainian air force
to defend themselves
against some Russian fighter jets
and ground forces
helping bog down the Russian invasion.
This was celebrated as part of Ukraine’s
remarkable resistance early on in the war.
It's a function of both Ukrainian success
and also some surprising
shortcomings in Russian military capability.
But it might not last much longer.
When you compare the Russian military and
the Ukrainian military there is no comparison.
In every major metric of power, the Russian
military is far more powerful
including when it comes to aviation.
Russia has more than ten times the number
of fighter aircraft as Ukraine.
And so far, they haven’t really used them.
It's possible over the coming days and weeks
that Putin and his military leaders decide
to make greater use of Russian aircraft.
And I think that's already happening.
They're entering a new phase where, in my
view, they're systematically
using air power in part
to systematically attack civilians and civilian
infrastructure.
That means the Russians still
could win air superiority
which would help speed up their invasion,
and likely cause significant civilian casualties.
So, Ukraine’s allies are frantically trying
to keep that from happening.
Many countries are sending weapons
that Ukrainian ground troops can use
to shoot down Russian aircraft.
And there have been talks about
sending Ukraine planes.
But there’s also been talk of
another kind of help: a no-fly zone.
Ukrainian president Volodmyrr Zelenskyy has
asked NATO, the western military alliance,
to declare a no-fly zone.
A number of US foreign policy experts
have called for a limited no-fly zone
and a recent poll shows 74% of Americans
think the US should declare one.
So, what is a No-Fly Zone?
Basically it’s a geographic area, where
certain plains are prohibited from flying.
The point of NATO declaring
a No-Fly Zone over Ukraine
would be to prevent Russia from
winning air superiority
thereby protecting Ukraine’s
military and civilians.
But what makes a no-fly zone complicated
is how NATO would have to enforce it.
To propose the no-fly zone in Ukraine
if you're going to be serious about it,
you have to consider that to enforce it
to make it a real thing
you would actually have to shoot down
Russian aircraft.
This means NATO would be directly
participating in the conflict
escalating the war to involve
the US and most of Europe.
The establishment of a no-fly zone
sooner or later
puts us in a high risk of direct combat.
And don't for a minute think that
you can control how that escalates.
Once one aircraft gets shot down,
whether it's ours or theirs
all bets are off on what happens next.
Russia is a nuclear armed power and Putin's
been making a lot of threats to suggest that
he thinks nuclear weapons might be an option.
All this would also be true of a
"limited no-fly zone"
which would only cover certain areas, but
would be enforced in the same way.
Putin has vowed to treat anyone imposing a
no-fly zone as a “participant in the conflict”.
And, so far, president Biden and NATO leaders
have ruled it out.
So for now, even while its allies send weapons
Ukraine will have to do the fighting themselves.
Every bone in my body wants to help Ukrainians.
They're fighting for all of us, and I weep
when I see some of these images.
But I think we should do all that we can
to help Ukraine
while also doing everything we can to avoid
direct conflict with Russia.